hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from the ftx crypto
cup uh it is anish giri versus
yanipanishi so the two of them already
faced off against each other quite a lot
that they played in the candidates
tournament
together and not so long ago and uh if
you remember giri was very very close to
winning the candidates he finished only
one point behind nipple in third place
uh whereas of course we know that nepal
will challenge magnus in november in
dubai
uh but this game it really uh it's it
really features in
a moment that's very very hard to
explain but uh
you'll see what i mean when we reach
this it's it's a very very
interesting game so gary with the white
pieces opens with
d4 uh sorry about that
uh we have knight to f6 by nipple uh c4
we have g6 uh knight to c3 and the d5 so
the uh
groomfield defense is on the board
nipple plays this quite a lot we have c
captures knight captures and now
at knight just e4 chasing away the
knight they're going for the exchange
variation of the groomfield
captures captures and bishop to g7 so
all very very standard stuff
we have knight to f3 uh c5 attacking
that center since
the rook is still on a1 uh rook to b1
getting broke out of harm's way and now
we have castles by nipple we have bishop
to e2
and now knight to c6 putting more
pressure on the center
all been played before nothing new here
we have d5 now
attacking the knight here also asking
maybe are you interested in this
pawn here uh but this is a very well
known line so usually people don't
don't grab this pawn so knight's the e5
with knight captures bishop captures and
now queen to d2 defending this
c3 pawn now uh nepo goes after it with
queen to a5 now threatening to win
geary's queen here
and rook to b3 this is how geary defends
with e6
now uh white king is still in the center
of the board so it makes sense uh for
you to open up
a lot lines of attack uh we have f4 by
anish adjacing away this bishop
bishop to g7 and c4 now adding more
pressure to the center
and now look at the geary's uh strong
center here if
you imagine him getting moves like f4
and uh e4
e5 and d6 in it's going to be very very
tough
to play this already getting a pass pawn
on the d file
and here there are some moves the uh
where queen capture uh some games were
queen captures and d2 was played also
queen to c7 is a known move
uh but the move that nipple plays is a
new move so after queen to d8 uh we have
a completely new game already as
of move 15. so let's see how anish deals
with this he
challenges the dark square bishop this
is uh by far black's strongest piece uh
for the moment even stronger than the
queen i would say
uh bishop captures on b2 not really
anything you can do about this
gear we will capture the bishop on the
next move so here near port trades we
have captures captures and the now
e5 trying to weaken white's very strong
center
and it's a very clever idea because if
you capture then you can go for this
check and after the king moves you're
going to eliminate the e4 pawn go after
the e5 pawn and now after this is
defended uh just rook e8 and you will
win this pawn as well
so for example sound like bishop f3
we're going to capture here and let's
say captures captures and you get this
position white that does have a past
d-pawn but not not much for for
black to worry about here uh so instead
after this e5 move
uh we have castles by anish and now
comes queen to d6
adding more defense to the pawn here and
now just uh
well a nice nice active square for the
queen
as as active as you can find and here we
have
f5 and f5 is an incredibly uh
tough move to face because you know that
f6 is coming if you play something weird
let's say play b6 f6
is coming and then you might uh you
might find yourself in
some sort of a mating net so instead
after f5 we have g
captures uh e captures on f5 and now of
course uh
f6 is still coming so nipple has to play
f6 himself
and now his king is a bit open but uh
you can imagine maybe if this bishop
gets developed maybe you can bring the
king over to h8
maybe you can double rooks on the g file
and maybe you can do some
some damage here so here we have rook to
b3
uh gary of course knows that now it's
time to shift to the rook over to the
kings side and it makes sense to do this
second rook lift so bishop to d7 a very
tricky idea uh offering the the b7 pawn
for some development uh but uh gary of
course not interested in that he's
interested in the attack and he jumps in
with queen to h6
i'm just gonna show a different line
because it's an extremely
uh strong one and even even try and
pause the video here and try to find
this idea uh because if you find this
then there is no defending black's
position so uh feel free to pause the
video here and
try well win this game for geary uh
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding other
uh either gears move
the one that i've shown you so
congratulations if you found that
but also if you found bishop to h5 and
this is just
an incredibly strong move because it
takes away the f7 square from this rook
and now there's really not all that much
you can do here queen to h6
is coming and then rook to g3 is coming
and now if you try something like let's
say bishop to e8 you want to
trade off this the strong piece we're
still going to play queen to h6
and now after the bishop gets traded off
now rook the g3 check
will win the game uh because now you
can't really move the king you're
getting checkmated
so you have to move the king here but
now the kingston
king hunt starts rook g7 checking it
we're gonna capture with checking we'll
move
we're gonna capture here and then it's
just a very very
tough position to play we can capture
here we can double up rooks on the b
file uh this is just uh complete
annihilation
so it was in the position but okay these
are rapid games of course uh
players cannot see everything we with a
queen to h6 by an ish
it's seemingly the same thing but not
really because now uh
nipple has the f7 square available for
his rook and that's exactly what he goes
for
uh we have rook calculus on b7 now now
is as good time as any to grab this pawn
uh you might uh go for bishop to h5 now
but now it's not
as potent you're just going to play rook
to g7 and now it's uh well
still of course much better for white
but there is no clear way how to
break through so instead uh anish grabs
the b7 pawn and
now uh rook the g7 now nipple of course
will play king to h8 he's going to bring
the other rook to j8 and he will try to
get some sort of an attack of his own
going
so bishop to f3 uh adding a defender
already to the g2 pawn the bishop will
come here
to also help out with the defense of
this pawn uh you can't really
move the bishop otherwise you're getting
checkmated so the bishop is stuck on d7
for the moment
uh king the h8 and now bishop to e4 by
an each
uh we have rook uh ate the g8 now
doubling up on the g file
uh putting pressure on g2 for the moment
the bishop is defending it so it's not
really an issue
uh rook captures on a7 anish grabs yet
another pawn and now his position is
better he he's the one
uh sort of attacking but not really as
the bishop no longer can be used as an
attacking piece so the the bishop's time
to shine was at the moment
bishop to h5 should have been played and
now it's going to be it's going to be
very difficult and
you always have to worry about all of
this pressure on the g file but he does
have the past a pawn
and that's also one of the winning
conditions if you
if you're able to start pushing that
pawn all the way up the board
will be very good for you so here queen
to b6 nipple finds the
basically the only good move this is how
you activate the queen by
attacking the rook so here rook to a3
and queen to b2 now
so that pawn wasn't really a free pawn
it activated black's position quite a
lot as now there's a triple attack here
on the g2 pawn
and there is only one one really good
move okay you could defend with queen h3
guards
both of them but rook to g3 is much
better so this is what anishi does
and now queen to d4 with check this now
connects
and now uh giri loses the bishop so king
to h1 we have queen captures on e4
so now a nipple is up a piece but it's
not a very impressive piece this
dark this uh light square bishop uh
not a lot of squares for it so here we
have queen captures on f6
uh and now comes queen captures on c4 so
attacking this rook on f1
we have rook to b1 and here there are a
couple of good moves for black
you could play some like bishop to c8
you could play something like bishop to
b5
that's that's a weird arrow bishop to b5
simply prevent that rook from going up
with any tempo
but if you move the rook to a weird
square also just queen to f1 you have to
uh you know be mindful of of the
checkmates
so here uh we have bishop e8 by nipple
but now this simply doesn't work this
entirely
loses the game for him but it's uh very
interesting how
this may or may not happen so here anish
captures on g7
we have rook captures on g7 and now he's
still down a bishop and
there's really no good way to activate
because if you bring the rook up
then you're just getting checkmated so
what do you do here
well here geary just played queen to f8
check rook to g8
queen back to f6 check rook g7 and here
he repeated moves and after rook to g7
they agreed uh to a draw but there is
something better here and it's
absolutely incredible because okay here
i prepared it for you so
you can check it out let me just find it
yeah this is it
this was the exact time on the clock
when this game was drawn i'm just going
to make it like really
really big here so you can see it uh
maybe there's a better place to put it
no there isn't
uh i'm just gonna put it here okay i'm
i'm gonna block uh
tal for a moment so sorry about that but
just uh so you guys see it
so here you can see that they still had
uh anish had 8 minutes and 28 seconds on
the clock whereas nipple had
10 minutes and 33 seconds on the clock
uh and it's really incredible because
there's a spectacular winning idea here
so while they drew the game uh you are
i imagine comfortable at your own home
so feel free to pause the video and
win this game for a niche while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not repeating moves like anish did and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
it's actually queen captures on e5 and
although it looks weird in such an
intense position just grabbing a pawn
there's no defense now the bishop is
under attack
and that's one of the reasons why the
bishop is uh
really bad on e8 and would have been
okay on c8 for example
but here it's a it's a direct target and
uh
there's just no no no stopping uh
uh losing this uh and i'm gonna show you
why because whatever you play
let's say you try something like bishop
to f7 you allow rook to ba to check and
now you can block with the bishop
which is perfectly fine but now comes
rook captures and g8 with
check and the rook is pinned the rook
cannot capture so the king has to
capture and now queen to e8 will be
checkmate there is nothing for you to do
here and there are
a lot of other options you could try
like you could try queen the a4
just defend the bishop like this but now
we get this
f6 move in and that's it there's no no
defense here if you try something like
rook f7
then comes rook to e1 now with the
thread of just queen captures bishop
here
and the the the king does not have
access to the g7 square so that's a
pretty pretty big deal and if you try
something like rook to f8
then simply f7 a nice discovered
checkmate
so there's also that and another thing
you could try
let's say uh to defend the bishop not
queen to a4 not bishop to f7 and we
could try something like uh
uh bishop to b5 just prevent the rook
from uh ever
reaching that square but it doesn't
matter we're just going to play f6
push the rook back and after rook moves
anywhere because we only wanted the g7
square taken away from the black king so
now after the rook moves
now queen b8 check and that's it rook
has to block and then queen captures
will be checkmate
so there are some other possibilities
but these are the ideas why it's
impossible to defend this position
uh but it's uh it's not okay if it was
like a few seconds on the clock or even
maybe a minute or maybe
a little bit under a minute it's
understandable to take a draw here
but uh i mean uh giri is a very strong
player i mean he finished
third in the candidates tournament and
him missing this idea
is uh well to me it's simply incredible
not finding queen captures on e5
and it really shows something that i've
mentioned quite a lot in my uh
videos that nippo is like okay maybe uh
double
dubo attacks like tal no there's no
denying that but nepo he's able to
hypnotize his opponents like tal and
he's always playing these positions
where he's like minus one minus two
minus
five and then he just uh you know uh
sort of sort of makes it work and here
uh it's it's a completely lost position
and
geary with almost nine minutes on the
clock uh nipples somehow
hypnotized him and it's not like they
were playing over the board so
geary could see that he's maybe very
calm he's very
overconfident even uh
it was just uh you know a game over or
an online game so you don't even see
your opponent so it's a
really really interesting and i would be
very interested interested to hear uh
how how this happened and why didn't
gary even try to to give this position
maybe
a minute or two or even seven because
you can always force
force to draw so really uh incredible
stuff and
uh yeah i mean that's chess weird stuff
happens in chess
as i always say so this is one of one of
those moments
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh
i imagine uh anish will not be very
happy with himself but he's doing very
well in the tournament so that's all
that matters these are only the
preliminaries
uh but yeah uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank devon
shah
and aman patel barry mcmurdock pratt
mahajan
caleb ewing and mikhail volska for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh most likely with another game from
the final day of the preliminaries
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day